έτσι για μένα ήταν εύκολο η μεδοκιμή ξεκίνησε με οκτώ συνεργάτεσ ήταν πουλημικρόημένατα κυρπια την
εξέλιξη που ήλθε δηλαδή βρίσκεται στις διακόσες ις σχειρότερες εταρίες του κόσμου και με μια
μελέτη που καναύρικ ότη σχεδόντρα ποσχεκατομήρία κόσμος παγκοσμίως χρησιμοποιά τα προϊόντω σας ότα ξεκινούσαε το
εδομτα έι περιμένατα αυτή την ανάπτυξη κοιτάξτε εγώ ότι κάνω το αγαπό και αυτό ο
εκανατότε ασφαλώς είχε ολι μου την αγάπη και την αφωσίωση δεν έβλεπα ένα τέλος κάπου
δηλαδή πούμε να κάνω κάτι το οποίο νκαλύπτημο ότι λέμες ότη ευκωσία τ τιλάρμακα αλλά
ήθελα να κάνω κάτι επαγκόσμιο και ξεκινήσαμε αμε αμέσως με εξαγωγιές εξαογίε τη μέση ανατολή
από τις πρώτες αγορές ήταν ι βιρητός ήταν το ιράκαι πολύ εργότερα σε αλλαμέρη όπως
την ευρωπή και λιπ κανείς δεν περιμένει εξαρχής το μέγεθος το οποίο μπορεί να φτάσει
αλλάφυσικά το επιθυμή στο βάθος να το φτάσει και αυτά το πράγμα έχει συμβίμα μας
και χαίρουμε που αναγνωρίστηκε η προσπάθεια μου σύντομα και στην κύπρο γιατί κύπρος επήρξεμεα δύσκολη
αγορά επειδή όλα έχουμε σανα καταναλωτες να μην όχει να μην εμπιστεύομαστε να μη στηρίζουμε
τόσο ναιριακάπροναι ναι η γενικά αυτό